docteur storm nous vous avons donné six
ans et des millions de dollars pour un
résultat inexistant pourquoi ça
changerait maintenant red richard's il
sait répondre à des questions qu'on n'a
même pas encore commencé à se poser
c'est l'occasion de lever un voile sur
notre planète et peut-être même de la
sauver je vous présente ma fille suzanne
tu cherches la célébrité je veux que mes
travaux aient un sens
je n'ai prête il n'aime pas recevoir des
ordres et encore moins de la part de
quelqu'un qui refuse qu'on lui en donne
te laisse pas malade et par des geeks en
blouse blanche s'il insiste je sais
qu'il appelle monsieur muscle je trouve
que tu détend l'atmosphère
non ce que vous avez créé ici est
monumentale
vous êtes en pleine possession de vos
moyens
ouais ça roule nous avait percé le
voyage transhumance ylonen
je crois pas
dites moi une seule chose où sont mes
enfants il y a quatre survivants
tous montrent des aptitudes physiques
exceptionnelles
je veux seulement guérir mes amis on en
guérit pas de ça
nous pouvoir servir l'humanité
tu as ouvert une porte que tu ne s'est
pas refermé
pas idée de ce qui va venir
alors dis-moi ce qui va venir
la fin
si vous voulez l'empêcher de nuire
il faudra mobiliser toutes vos forces
il lui faut combien de temps pour entrer
e minute
peut être un peu moins